So with hiring it can be a mixed bag.
You could randomly reach out to
a bunch of different companies that
will sell you databases of people who
are prospectively looking for jobs and
you can sit down and rifle through
a couple of thousand resumes.
Done that, not so fun.
Or you can take advantage of your
existing social networks and
I don't mean just jumping on Facebook
and saying hey, we're hiring..
I mean press the flesh,
who do you know that is talented within
a specific skill set you're looking for?
You know people or
you know people who know people and
reaching out through that
network is actually really,
really powerful in being able
to hire the right talent and
temperament within your company because
doing otherwise is kind of toxic.